what one hope of a lot of people in
crypto world is that some of these
traditional legacy players can come in
and legitimize the space right and so
ice for example coming in and saying hey
we're gonna create this platform right
we're gonna kind of put our name our
experience behind this how do you think
that impacts the space not only from the
development of crypto assets and
networks but then also from the
institutional investors perspective yes
I think the ice announcement is one that
I'm still processing in one way I do you
think it's really good because it adds
legitimacy to the space I think
particularly big coin right Bitcoin is
that asset that it's been in the market
long enough there's enough data around
that investors are starting to get more
comfortable with the idea of bitcoins I
think that's familiar exactly right but
also that body of knowledge exists and
we now know how to deal with it
most importantly you know how to value
it and Mark it I think that's a huge
problem we don't really talk about as
much so bitcoins starting to feel
familiar so ice coming out and saying
look we're gonna enable you to really
easily with a trusted partner that you
already can trade with is all Bitcoin
like that's that's material I think the
hard part is is once the financial
institutions start moving in they're
gonna do what they do right like banks
got a bank so people started talking to
you now about the idea of extending
leverage on top of Bitcoin and I'm like
oh it's coming [ __ ] Quinn was created so
I do think there's this component and
what I always say is there's the
revolution camp which is where I started
out when I got into Bitcoin like down
with the bank's like [ __ ] the
institutions and that's one narrative
and then there's the evolution narrative
which is hey we're gonna start with
something that looks smells tastes feels
like what's already happening in the
world of institutional finance and then
over time it will involve inform to be
more reflective of all the technical
capabilities of a blockchain based asset
or cryptocurrency which which do you
think is more likely to occur today the
Revolution or the evolution okay so here
it actually depends on the broader macro
environment which is something I don't
think we think about often inside the
crypto bubble if we have another tooth
if we have another cyprus or another
greece then i think we're gonna go
revolution and the thing i always think
about is are we ready right like when
that narrative starts to really
accelerate and when people have that
impetus when there's that Matt what I
always think is path dependence right so
if we stay on the current path
we're gonna go evolution but if there is
a massive force that jolts us out of
that path then we're gonna go revolution